hello and welcome to this video on
playing down route 13 six nine okay
let's go for something else like Kings
Indian what is the route going to do
here okay hmm
that's what you get yeah for playing the
okay that is a quite uncommon way to
play it just cancelling no let me just
ninety seven and then see six usually
they trade on the age after exchanging
Queens
yeah my main idea now is to trying to
play against the weak entity Foursquare
I tried to trade this bishop against the
knight and so he is very much not
against it that's good now the knight
coming to the fore as looks very likely
to happen
yeah he will go but should be three I
guess
yeah and now I can't go 94 immediately
of course I just wonder if it is the
best way to play maybe he can take twice
actually add this isn't all that
fantastic I'm trying to provoke b5 this
is probably not working I mean not
working I mean he will probably not be
provoked to play it
he is provoked to play it okay as is
good this is good so let's prepare 94
maybe Bishop g4 is an idea now for him
it doesn't really react to anything what
I'm doing okay 94
you see that's going to be uncomfortable
you just take such that will at least
win some material I got d3 next yeah d3
is winning winning stuff okay the
question is how exactly what what am i
winning
I think Knight e5 is right 95 is Bastion
if I take a one he will take d7 but this
is a good move because the Queen has a
hard time to find a good square
it should cover the rook Queen B one
because I have neither three checks so
right here I'm changing and I have Queen
g5 check winning the rook the other
yeah lookup is good this is actually
quite and quite instructive to be honest
he didn't play it well but to Ted some
good instructive movements yeah him if
you take on e5 you should absolutely
take on d8 as well and now play Bishop
g5 195 one of the two this is some the
king's indian exchange variation which
is very young yeah very solid line for
white it's same castles I'm quite happy
with because I don't want to trade
Queens necessarily it's funny that
stockfish is evaluating the position
entirely wrong plus one is a bit of a
joke and this is that this is however a
fairly typical thing they tend to the
engines tend to completely miss evaluate
those positions it would go down by the
way if you give it more time if you give
it a lots more time at war it will go
down in the evaluation Quincy to c6 ko
this is very normal and now we're
starting with moves that I don't like
their Bishop g5 it doesn't really do
much because you definitely don't want
to take everyone f6 and weaken the dark
squares even more and it's a potential
tempo with 96 that I'm getting so this
is why I went 95 a3 and now I took this
opportunity to get Bishop g4 and the
bishop here is a fairly useless piece
that is happy to trade against this
because then my control of the d4 is
strengthened he should not play before
now definitely not
I think this is leading into the first
this leads to slight problems already
and the engine does not agree it's
interesting okay a five and now he
shouldn't play be fine really
anything else hmm engine doesn't really
mind to be fine more like much 92 okay
yeah I mean blacks position is quite
comfortable on it this is not really
paying attention to my idea right 92 is
better yeah that's definitely true this
is an idea maybe getting rid of the bad
bishop and now I now he has to move the
Queen to d1 after that the game is over
I'm just waiting just winning decisive
materially and there is no way now to
save material unprotected and sort of
unprotected it is too much against the
bishop on yourself yeah so the exchange
variation is not bad but you have to
really take on the agent I mean
realistically wide wide will draw a lot
here and not win very much but it is
something that that can be played in the
right situation okay guys thanks for
watching